So, now that we have seen, what the
performance looks like when we refuse to make any
predictions. Let's see what the performance is with
the so called not-taken prediction, which amounts to simply
fetching the next instruction, as if none of
the instructions was a taken branch. When we refuse
to predict anything, a branch, every branch, would
cost us 3 cycles. And even a non-branch instruction
would cost us 2 cycles, even in
a relatively shallow five-stage pipeline. When we predict
that the instruction we are fetching is not a taken branch, we get that branches
now cost us 1 or 3 cycles. One cycle for not taken branch. Three cycles
for taken branch. And a non-branch instruction always
costs us 1 cycle. Because, in that case,
the not-taken prediction is always correct. So as
we can see, the predict not-taken always wins over
refusing to predict. For non-branches, we are always 1
cycle better. For branches, we are either the same
or 2 cycles better. This is why every
processor that has a pipeline will do some branch
prediction, even if the prediction it is doing is
simply increment the PC and fetch the next instruction.
Note that that type of prediction is really cheap. All you
have to do is increment the PC. You don't actually have to
know anything about branches or other instructions. So it's very easy to
do it. You have to be able to increment the PC anyway.